coach thanks for joining us where are
you right now Dan I'm in Miami on the
bus headed to the airport to go to to go
to San Antonio where is your designated
seat on the bus okay I got the front
front left seat okay now if somebody sat
in your seat what happens well it
depends who it is someone else on the
staff they're gonna I'm just gonna stare
at them until they get on comfortable
and get up and leave
what if Alonzo is sitting there when you
walk on the bus I'd sit down next to him
put my arm around and see what he wanted
to talk about tell he got uncomfortable
and left you said that he was probably
the best player on the floor last night
against Miami why because of how many
ways he impacts the game he sent his own
force defense that I have a goal out a
challenge out to our team post all-star
to be a top-ten defensive squad for the
last 25 games and he set the tone for
last night he hasn't started so he's
coming back from injury
he's been on a minutes restriction that
he just he was flying around the court
making unselfish plays on both ends and
just really you know yeah I agree with
you I think Lonzo and it's such an
underrated aspect of his game is a great
that has the chance to be a great
defender but you know you were saying he
was doing everything last night he was
doing everything listen yeah there's a
case to be made that Isiah Thomas was
what was the best player he had a pretty
special night as well well I shouldn't
say special that's what he kind of he's
proven that he'd be does of his league
that Brandon Ingram was really really
good as to I just for me in the in the
challenge being on defense that's why I
kind of I got kind of threw coop ronzo
out there as far as being the best
player on the court we're talking to
coach Luke Walton the liquors heading to
San Antonio with a game tomorrow night
what's the last time you played full
court
last time I played full court yeah at
least a year ago and it doesn't work for
me it's not worth if I play full court I
can't walk for like TV so did you play
full court against your team with your
team no no not a chance that's more like
a coach's game that and even in a
coach's game like I will tell you this
like I won the series I talked a lot of
trash but at the end of the day when I
had to sit in an ice bath just confirmed
on the half-court player now if we had a
one-on-one tournament with NBA coaches
where are you a number one seed yeah
absolutely
oh it was one it's one-on-one half-court
right yeah yeah yeah okay um being a
hundred percent on the one seed well who
else would be a one seed you know Chloe
Berg trying to think of so much the
effort looks like he's in pretty good
shape still I'm trying to think of some
of the younger coaches when Schneider uh
Quinn Quinn would be up there maybe like
bracket right yeah yeah we do it for
bracket so there's four of us kickers
not there not these thieves more of an
elliptical pops not on there standing on
how about Spoelstra I don't know much
about suppose this game you know I was
thinking maybe tyloo if you could fill
play a little bit yeah but I think I'm
the overall no hornacek horny can still
play right we were looking to see how
many people how many players are older
than you and the NBA do you know how
many players are older than you you're
37 38 in a month I believe right
Vince Carter for sure yeah not Zack give
me a couple more I plays with San
Antonio pal Gasol Manu Ginobili
Ginobili yeah my older than pal Jason
Terry JT JT was a was a see here my
freshman year at everything we played
together
I got dirk nowitzki you got Dirk yeah
Jamal Crawford I believe is older than
you I think he is that's it that's
that's and I think credit whenever we
play those guys and I want that they
don't just sit on the vans either like
they still get it done at the NBA like
my body hurts watching film on them play
at this level it's just incredible that
they can still they can still get the
job done explain to me what's happened
since early January with this team
because the record is up there with you
know top three or top four in the league
so what started what clicked you had the
trade deadline so this is before that so
what is it well we've getting familiar
with each other we were playing you know
we weren't winning games at the
beginning of the year when we were
playing really hard and competing and
guys were you know bought into playing
the right way we just weren't ready to
to finish games out and win close games
because that's like anything else is a
skill that needs to be learned and when
you've got young players that are still
developing and learning the NBA game
when it's all about it's tough to win we
were right in every single game with the
way we were playing and then I think we
hit a lot of we got a lot of injuries
during December and we happen to play
the hardest schedule in the history of
the NBA that month with the Warriors
three times and Houston three times and
on the road we slowly started getting
healthy again and I think our guys you
know the thing I
I like most about our group of players
is their work ethic and no matter if
we're winning or losing when we're on
the practice court they bust their tails
and they kind of started getting healthy
again and and just kept working and they
they just had growth I mean you get you
become better by failing and working
harder and you know realizing what you
need to be better at and they've they've
done a really nice job which is
continuing to grow as a group and now
you know here we are later in the season
and as you should be we're playing
better basketball than we were at the
beginning with you talking to Luke
Walton the Lakers head coach joining us
Continental Tire coaches corner has the
crossover replaced dunking on somebody
like breaking ankles I don't think so I
still prefer a nice as well we were say
if you're talking about the James Harden
wanted yes kind of the extreme didn't
ever happen to you Luke no I hope you
ones I was too slow to if you crossed me
over you Crawley just end up right back
in front of me because I have reacted
did you get posterized
I'm sure I did there's one where you go
oh might like Vince Carter didn't like
go up and dunk in your face or somebody
like that yet you had none of those
where you got post or us oh that makes
sense
I couldn't if I couldn't take a charge I
wasn't gonna try to jump with somebody
like if I was in there in time to get my
body in thought of of always I was just
gonna do a flyby and run micron my my
lane I got you with a dunk your
posterizing Ronny Turiaf yeah I do I got
that this is how you looked at him here
Luke you're staring him down after you
dunk on him
it was that's much longer teammate at
that point so me and him were really
close and I got I
I had that picture blown up and I you
know I have it at my house in a frame
and every time roni roni or any of the
other teammates come over I like like
normally just just in the closet like I
don't even
it's literally like it collects us
unless any of my teammates come over and
then I like to bring it out put it front
and said I love it I love that if it
could Kobe give you ten good minutes
right now give you more than that he
might hurt himself because he think he
plays much anymore but he would give you
ten intense minutes see what he would
hard foul some people and he did a
game-winner if the game was now a safe
travels congrats on the season so far we
always appreciate you joining us thank
you Luke that's Luke Walton
they always out voices me and then we
get him in the morning and that voice is
even deeper there imagine Kobe showing
up Continental Tire Coach's Corner
brings you Luke Walton I love
Continental Tire it's the exclusive
Tiger the Dan Patrick show no matter
where you drive or what you drive
Continental designs tires for what you
do for more information visit
Continental Tire come Continental Tire
for what you do for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]